こんばんわはじめしゃちょーです、こんばんわはじめしゃちょーです
あんまり　こういうこと動画で言っちゃうと
心配されるので言いたくないんですけど
あのぉ・・・
すげぇ二重だな
今世紀最大の二重だ！
こういうことあんまりいいたくないんですけども、
いや、そう　うれしそうな顔をするんじゃない(笑)
結構これ信憑性が高い話で‥
どこが取り憑かれているかといいますと
こちらのいつも動画とってる撮影部屋
でございます
やばい、かなりやばいと思います
僕自身、霊感がないので
なんとも言えないんですけど、
入った瞬間の気持ち悪い感じは
なんか、わかるんですよ
で、僕っ家結構いろんな友達とか後輩が
入ってくるんで
結⤴構な人が
「あの部屋ヤバいよ」と
あの部屋なんかいるよっていうことを
かなりの確率で言ってくるんですよ
ちょっと聞いてみようか
もしもし～
おつかれっす～
ねぇ、あのさぁ、
おいらっちのさぁ
撮影部屋ってさぁ
呪われてる説ある…？
”なんかねぇ、まず　空気が違うんすよね”
そう　そうっしょう
”なんだろう”
”まぁ場所的にもそうかもしんないけど”
”まぁ、なんか、やっぱり
”まぁよくないっちゃよｋ
というわけでですね
入った時の感覚が
ほかの部屋とは違うんですよ
僕の後輩の妹がすごい霊感持ってるらしくて
ぼくんちに来なくても
そらちぃもなぁ
そらちぃも一回言ってたんですよね
なんかこの部屋入るとけだるくなるんですよ
やる気を一切失う、みたいな
マサキ言ってたなぁ
マサキも言ってた気がするなぁ
もしもし？
明けましておめでとうございます
ねぇちょっとさぁ、
一つ聞きたいことがあるんだけどさぁ
おいらっちのさぁ
撮影部屋ってあるじゃん？奥の
あそこってさぁ
呪われてる説ない？結構
あるっしょ？
なんか心当たりあります？ちなみに
”心当たり？”
”あー、あれ”
”一時期入ったとき”
”めっちゃなんか頭痛くなった”
マジ…！？
”うん…”
結構色んな人が言うんですけど…
”えでも俺、それあって”
”あんまあの部屋入んなかったからｎ”
もう全員がですね、
割とこの撮影部屋に入ると
結構ヤバいっていう空気を感じるんですよ
僕は霊感ないし
なんか逆にこの部屋はなんか
僕はなにも感じないんですけども
基本的には皆やばい感じがするし、
頭痛くなるとか、入りたくないとか
そういうことを言っちゃうぐらい
ちょっと、ヤバい状態っぽいです…
割と困ってます…
一回入ってみますか
いやぁ、なんかねぇ
部屋の位置もあんまり良くないみたいなんすよね
入ってみます
あぁ…
うわぁ寒い…
鳥肌が、鳥肌がヤバい
わかるかなぁ
鳥肌が止まんないんですよ
パッと見そんなに
変なとこはないんですけど…
え…？？？
は…！？
今年結構運も悪いんで
割となんとかしなきゃな、と思っております
でなんか、アプリで
えぇ、怖いよぉ…
ひとまず…
除霊もできるの！？
（お経）
部屋で1人でいるのも怖いしさ、
だから最近友達呼ぶんすよ！
最近、毎晩のように友達と
遊戯王してて
1人でいるのが怖すぎて
部屋に一人でいたくないんすよ！
ほらもう
こんな鳥肌立ってますからね！？
アプリで出来るかわかんないんですけど
ひとまずちょっと、除霊だけやってみます
では…
行ってきます
入った時のこの
心霊の強度に、注目です
いきます…
あぁ～…
うわ、やっべ！
待ってマジで怖い
マジで怖い
もう700いきそうなんだけど…
うわ、うわ
ヤバい、マジヤバい×3
大丈夫かこれ…
うわ！8000いったよ今！
ヤバくないここ…
うわ！9000になった！！
ちょっと除霊、除霊します…
はい、というわけで
この部屋ちょっとヤバいっすね…
まぁ、アプリなんで
これ、ひょっとしたら
ただのごまかしにしか過ぎないかもしれないんですけど、
まぁ数字だけじゃなくて実際
かなりの人がですね、その…
この部屋の異常性を訴えているし
ちょっと近いうちにこの部屋はなんとかします…
わかんないっす。ひょっとしたら
その霊って
あの、全部悪い霊とは限らないじゃないですか？
なんか、いい霊もいるし悪い霊もいるから
ひょっとしたら
うわ寒いわ
まぁ一概に悪い霊とは言わないんですけども
ちょっとあんまり
これ以上なんかちょっとおかしなことがあったら
なんとかしようと思っております…
除霊の方法とか僕もちょっと
よくわからないので
よかったら、コメント欄でなにか教えてください（o_ _)ｏ））
ぜひ皆さん、
ちょっとヤバいような場所があったら
気を付けてください…
じゃあな…
とりあえずヒカキンさんの写真だけでも外しておこう…